laurent cesari bonjour je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur le plateau de rtl france alors
on lisait le parti républicain
aujourd'hui divisée sur l'assaut du
capitole quels sont les deux visions
finalement qui s'opposent au sein des
républicains sur le sujet c'était est
simple vous avez là la position de trump
comme l'a dit votre reportage qui
minimisent très fortement la la portée
de l'événement long le ramenant à une
action politique ordinaire et en face
vous avez
la position qui est celle des
deux cas étaient soutenus par mcconnell
qui est celle de dogo de liste chez nec
et la numéro 3 du parti qui appartient à
la commission denquête la commission d'
enquête de la chambre des représentants
sur sur donc cette émeute l'apostât
comme ça du 6 janvier
2021 et qui que vous savez met en cause
directement entre eux puisque des
documents de des archives nationales ont
été récemment fourni à cette condition
est donc il ya deux
représentants républicains tout le reste
et démocrates qui sont pas trompés istin
pas du tout et ils viennent donc de se
faire
comment dire que condamner très
officielle sur les sanctionnés par la
comité républicain et même mcconnell qui
a l'habitude de soutenir ses collègues
parlementaires c'est important pour lui
pour pour conforter sa position de chef
de deux chefs de groupe
républicain du groupe parlementaire
prend les gros les soutiens et donc vous
avez cette division en fait sur ce
qu'est le 6 janvier 2021 il y à aussi
l'ancien vice-président américain de
mike pence qui s'est opposé à à donald
trump il ya quelques jours là encore
c'était toujours au sujet du capitole
bien entendu il ya dix ans c'était au
sujet de ce sur quoi portait notre
puisque seuls à savoir si le comptage
des voix le comptage des voix de
l'élection présidentielle de novembre
2000 21 la lola loi sur la certification
des résultats électoraux et une voix
très ancienne qui remonte aux années
1880 qui est mal rédigé qu'ils laissent
la place à beaucoup d'ambiguïtés alors
on saura jamais si trump crois vraiment
qu'il a gagné l'élection ou non ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il a encouragée
peines à utiliser tous les toutes les
astuces juridiques possibles pour
assurer quand même le
résultat favorable à trump et
mais penske n'a pas voulu n'a pas voulu
aller jusqu'à ce point est donc la
rupture est là justement cet assaut du
capitole il ya une commission d' enquête
qui est en cours qu'est ce qu'on en sait
ce que ça elle a permis de révéler
quelques éléments par ce conte province
temps c'est vraiment en cours ce qui
paraît très nettement c'est un soutien
très nette de trump osé aux émeutiers
sur quoi on se dirige c'est vraiment une
implication personnelle de de trump ou
de ses proches comme giuliani oui mais
où même sa une partie de sa famille en
tout cas nous sommes à quelques mois des
législatives de mi mandat quelles
conséquences pour le parti républicain
ses divisions actuelles est ce qu'il ya
un risque d'affecter les chances
républicaine de reprendre le contrôle du
congrès alors ça c'est plus difficile à
savoir je pense que
j'irai que c'est une affaire interne aux
républicains s est ce que ce sera trump
lui-même qui sera continuera à être la
personnalité dominante pour l'instant il
est toujours le plus favori l'homme le
plus le plus le préfet les électeurs
diront nous de la base mais il y en a
d'autres qui sont sur des lignes assez
proches comme le gouverneur de
californie plus elle et c'est plus poli
c'est peut-être qu'ils pourraient un
jour prendre comment dire la succession
en revanche on voit bien que ce sur quoi
tous les républicains sont unis quelles
que soient leurs rivalités internes
c'est une opposition frontale un blocage
absolu à tout ce que peut proposer bas
et dames et commises ont toujours
l'appui de fêtes de deux sénateurs
démocrates man ciné cinéma qui ont fait
qu'ils occupent en fait sa vie avec les
républicains pour tout bloquer je pense
que cette ligne d'opposition
ne bougera pas est-ce que ça assurera
une victoire de wiz hâtive du mandat ça
c'est un petit peu tôt pour dire mais à
mon avis la ligne 2 bougera pas quels
que soient les rivalités internes au
sein du parti mais est-ce que c'est
toujours donald trump chiens et
finalement qui incarne aujourd'hui cette
opposition à joe biden où il ya d'autres
figures qui pourraient se détacher
justement comme je vous dis je comme je
vous disais ce qui peut bouger c'est la
position de trump au sein du parti parce
qu'il vous avait des d'être en piste
plus jeune qui est que trump avait
adoubé comme comme de centimes dans leur
californie qui est qui commence à
vouloir voler de leurs propres ailes
et puis vous avez la ligne de la ligne
parlementaire de mcconnell qui est
partie comment dire qui est patronne qui
s'appelle faire ils ont une rivalité
personnelle très forte et enfin vous
avez mais ces minoritaires maintenant la
ligne disons néoconservatrice plus
ancienne de cheney qui est en train de
se faire d'eux de se faire mal voir de
la direction du parti cela dit je pense
que quand même il y a des points communs
sur entre tous ces gens par exemple ils
peuvent très bien tout continue à
s'entendre sur les guerres culturelles
l'opposition ce qu'ils appellent le haut
qui se verra ça ce sont des thèmes
fédérateurs qui peut tenir au moins que
plus qu'à obtenir au moins quelques mois
merci en tout cas laurent cesari pour
votre éclairage ce matin sur notre
plateau je le rappelle vous êtes
professeur d'université en histoire des
relations internationales contemporaines